はいはじめ超質問コーナー毎度大変お待たせいたしましたと言いたいところなんです
けどもあのですねとてもありがたいことなんですけども質問コーナー早く机
遅い何してんだなんだとてもねありがたいことなんですよ分かってるそれは楽しみにし
てくれるって言うのはとっても僕にとってうれしいことなんですけどもう何だろうなぁ
早く作れとか言う
言われるとねやっぱりちょっとこちらとしてはなんていうのかなちょっと僕を作りたい
んですけども急いで作ってもいいものはできないんですよ僕とスターさんのコメント欄
をねギリギリまで見て讃えたいなっとも質問しっかり見つけてやりたいんでなかなかね
その募集してから時間がかかるんですよ動画を作るのになんで僕はあえてこの日に出し
ますということ言わないんですけども早く
出せとか遅いとか言われるとねちょっと焦っちゃうしちょっとなんかやらされてる感が
出ちゃって何わかる所
宿題が出ましたお母さんとかね家族の人があんた早く宿題しなさいって言うとやる気
なくなるじゃんそういう感じで自分がやりたいと思ってても胸にこうやれやれって言わ
れるとちょっとなんかやる気がなくなっちゃうみたいな感じなんですもんコーナー待っ
てくださったり楽しみにしてくださるのはとてもありがたいんですけども
僕のペースでやりたいと思ってるんであんまり煽られると6木綿名しちゃうんであまり
で煽る行為はおやめくださいね親に勉強しなさいって言われて嫌な気分になる人達の
気持ちですもしまたね質問コーナーする時があったら時間かけて作りたいんで温かい目
で待っていただければありがたいですこれ
らもよろしくお願いしますでは早速してもこのいきましょう
いやーもうなんかどうでもいいやどうせ選ばれないよねでもこんなやり取りをしている
とそれがもしかするとまさかの選ば0マザーが飲ま坂の
ぬこと言ってたらきちゃったりしてこんな話をしていると
もしかしてもしかすればまっさーかーの
ホントのホントに持ち出して嫌々始めもそこまで馬鹿ではないでしょ
でももしかしたらまさかのそのまさかのまさかのもしかしてそのままさんがあります
その真ん中という形わーラン何けどめちゃくちゃ多いな美味しい無事
がんばればなんでしめじって
ありがとうはあああああ
ああああああああ
廊下に立ちなさい
ねえなんではじめしながらくしゃみをしてくださいねこれいっかーっ
さっ派
なんでこれは全力で nikko に後にあなたのハートににこにこくにひろ届出
ゾーンニコニコあーダメダメだね初めはみんなのモーノーを頂点で来ちゃってください
3日にっこに良いあなたのハートににこにこに笑顔とできる
皆さんニコにかぁああ
100分間3段目初めはみんなの
もうの気持ち悪い始めればお手作業を何度もすることが多いですが
うおおおお行った無理休めとかってならないんですか僕の凄いところでトーク芸がない
ことなんだ
特別なことができないんですけども僕人維持できるっていうのがその続けることって
集中力ですね自分のしたいこと限定なんです
の猛獣全力だけはもうめちゃくちゃあー時はそれが僕の唯一の武器で叫ぶだよ馬鹿野郎
22財にもなってこんな夜中に避ける奴がいるぞもう
花アップは背後霊で叫んで下さいお願いします
まあ作業されないだろうなバッグわー
はいどれー
これ何声で大好き頭大丈夫か今までの動画の中で一番金を使ったものは何ですか
今までの動画で一番お金を使ったのギネス記録120万円ですイベントも盛り上がった
し生きてくれたみんなも楽しんでくれたんで僕が良かったですさぁカメラをアップして
もっともっといいよそしてスマイル
かっこいい始め
在り方をもらいながら等速直線運動あっはという位置で撮る飲めるんですか飲めねえ頭
通い
陳蘭
生き返ったきぞ命だ二大画面を赤く染めて区立中
wh
me
どーん
分
今話したい誰かがいるいない基本的に一人でいたいねできれば一人でいたいポッキー
食べたらぶってえした母
ああああああ
ぴ&そのままかじってください
味がねぇ
前転して壁走ってキメ顔で大輔氏を破ったとに思いっきり好きだぁーと叫びつつ実は
そうでもないと思いながらもそんなことをちょっと女た後思い勉強してください
おかしいなぁの全力でめぐみさんの真似しではいみなさんこんにちは仁チャンネルへ
ようこそ競争品紹介するのはこちら
リボルテック手袋ぼ
紹介ですこのホロヴィッツ素晴らしいも最高から毎年
の食べちゃいたいねこれウヴァヴァウバーイ最高も
たまんまいえしすぺっ
まずいますすいませんでした並みの低ように枝話し選手はじめよ
今着ている服を闇の力を解放し破り捨てるのだ
さぁさぁ
じゃあああああ
マミしてくれるんだよおおおおおクラッハイレベルですね今回もたくさんの質問
ありがとうございました
スキン家だとちょっとペースが速いと思ったんでですねまあまあ食べ僕の良き
タイミングで質問コーナーやろうと思います次会えるときは皆そうかっかせずね冷静に
冷静に伸びると気楽に待ってくれると北防波作ります
ベア皆さん次回の動画でお会いしましょうじゃじゃーん
ani
me
います